the terminator franchise is the longest
running time travel action film series
and has gotten increasingly convoluted
as its heroes continue to fight the war
against machines if all the alternate
timelines of the terminator franchise
make your head spin here's an
explanation for each ending in the
series so far
in james cameron's action-packed classic
the terminator we meet two men who are
sent back to 1984 to change the fate of
the planet one is an unstoppable machine
with the face and skin of a man that's
arnold's t-800 here to terminate sarah
connor and stop the human rebellion
before it begins the other is kyle reese
a soldier sent by sarah's son john who
has been given the mission of ensuring
her survival until she can give birth to
the future resistance leader john has
given reese a photograph of sarah to
identify her and he's fallen in love
with her before the two even meet
luckily for him sarah reciprocates his
feelings resulting in jon's conception
this means that if john connor had never
instructed cal rhys to go back in time
and protect sarah john never would have
been born in the first place it's a
confusing paradox but it's easy to
overlook considering how well everything
comes together in the film's final
moments in the climax of the terminator
rhys sacrifices his life to save sarah
completing his destiny at least in this
timeline after sarah manages to defeat
the t-800 and escape with her life a
flash forward reveals that she's
pregnant with reese's child sarah
records messages for jon informing him
of his complicated destiny in a scene
that sets up their relationship in the
sequel
if you don't send kyle you could never
be
god a person could go crazy thinking
about this
in the final moments a boy at a gas
station takes a polaroid photo of sarah
the same photo that rhys fell in love
with everything comes full circle
regardless of whether you prefer
terminator or terminator 2 it's hard to
deny that they're among the best action
movies of all time cameron's sequel to
the terminator is a non-stop thrill ride
that proves you don't need convoluted
twists to make a compelling time travel
story and as such it has the most
straightforward ending in the series in
its simplicity judgment day also brings
something to the table the other
terminator movies lack hope sarah and
john connor find themselves safe once
again after arnold's cyberdyne systems
model 101 now programmed to protect john
connor rather than kill him saves them
from the t-1000 in one of the film's
most iconic scenes the model 101 lowers
himself into a vat of molten steel after
explaining that he must destroy any
trace of future technology in the
present his sacrifice fills sarah with
hope for the first time she can imagine
a future where machines and humans live
together in harmony it's too bad that
things would only get worse for the
humans from here
while it's far from the best terminator
movie terminator 3 arguably has the
darkest ending of the series instead of
finishing on a victorious note like
james cameron's original films rise of
the machines ends with skynet finally
achieving self-awareness and global
domination at the end of the mindless
sci-fi romp that is terminator 3 john
connor and his future wife kate arrive
at crystal peak a decommissioned
military outpost where they had been
told they would be able to put an end to
skynet once and for all this was their
destination all along but in a
devastating twist the structure is
revealed to not be skynet's core instead
it is a fallout shelter and the end of
the human race is imminent the machines
won the moment skynet became self-aware
there was never any hope of stopping
them judgment day is here this take on
john's destiny is a subversion of the
expectations of the other movies he was
never meant to stop the war before it
began judgment day was an inevitability
instead he is meant to survive the
apocalypse in order to restart the human
race with kate
terminator salvation is the franchise's
take on a war movie and it's the only
one that doesn't feature schwarzenegger
in the title role starring christian
bale as john connor and the late anton
yelchin as calrisse salvation follows
the pair and their allies as they
attempt a covert mission to shut down
skynet's machine army the ending of this
one is fairly straightforward john
connor nearly gives his life rescuing
kyle reese ensuring his own birth then
former death row inmate marcus revealed
earlier to be part machine sacrifices
himself in the final moments literally
giving his heart to save jon according
to director mick g the original ending
the filmmakers had in mind was much
darker mcgee told io9 connor dies we're
in a room with all the people we care
about you take connor's likeness you put
it on the living machine of marcus he
sits up now looking like christian bale
takes a gun kills kate kills cow kills
star kills everybody eyes flare red the
end
this wasn't the only version of this
ending that was under consideration
according to screenwriter michael ferris
one scrapped ending showed connor's face
on marcus's body but didn't include the
evil turn the writer and director both
seemed to appreciate how ironic it would
be if the leader of the human resistance
was turned into a machine
terminator genesis was an attempt to
reboot the series by doing what the
franchise does best and worst making a
sequel to the terminator what boils down
to an alternate timeline version of
skynet's rise ends up being the most
complicated and convoluted in the series
long history the confusing writing of
genesis certainly applies to its ending
but to explain the ending we have to
start at the beginning after traveling
back to 1984 cal reese experienced his
visions from an alternate childhood he
never lived this splintering of the
timeline leads to rhys taking sarah
connor from 1984 and traveling to 2017
where the upcoming launch of an os named
genesis will lead to the creation of
skynet with the help of pops this
timeline's friendly version of arnold
schwarzenegger's terminator they stop an
evil cyborg john connor and take down
genesis to close the loop the trio
visits the adolescent version of reese
to get him to remember that genesis is
skynet the memory that set the whole
film into motion in the first place to
put it plainly kyle reese needs to tell
the younger version of himself to give
the future version of himself the
warning that causes this timeline to
exist if that can be considered plain
after all these time travel shenanigans
a mid-credits sequence shows it doesn't
really matter though genesis survived
the attack setting up the direct sequels
that were cancelled after the poor
reception of this fifth terminator film
the newest terminator movie is known
more for its controversial and secretly
great opening sequence than its ending
in the film's first moments sarah connor
and a teenage john connor are relaxing
at a beachside bar in guatemala enjoying
some much-needed r r then out of nowhere
a t-800 arrives to kill jon once again
but this time it actually succeeds
although dark fate diverges from the
established timeline it brought back
linda hamilton as sarah connor and rope
james cameron back in as a producer to
create the most well-received movie in
the franchise since t2 still the final
moments are a bit vague with regards to
where the future of the terminator
franchise is heading and whether or not
we'll ever be seeing these characters
again
i won't be back
in the climax of dark fate genetically
enhanced cyber soldier grace sacrifices
herself so future freedom fighter dany
can use her power source to defeat the
evil rev9 terminator this is grace's
fate and it needs to happen so dany can
live and fulfill her destiny in the
film's final scene sarah and danny visit
the childhood version of grace who is
currently 10 years old danny wants to
save her and prevent the events of the
movie from taking place but sarah knows
that they are inevitable dany must
accept that grace has to die to save the
world if not danny will die in her place
and the machines will undoubtedly win
after judgment day a dark fate indeed
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one